talk me through your the challenges that
you're facing with your energy bills at
the moment morning cake yeah I I mean
the rising costs I mean we're all
hearing about it the problem with that
business is that at the minute there was
no cap and now there is a cap coming in
but we need to know what that cap is
where it sits uh many people have got
their business uh energy contracts
signed up
um but are beginning to drop out of it
between now October and through to
December and uh our first quote for one
of our particular spaces has gone from
um 14 Pence per kilowatt hour up to one
pound and two pence per kilowatt hour so
and this is a place that uses uh 35
between 32 and 35
000 kilowatts per hour per month so it's
rising from around about 60 000 pounds a
year up to 420
000 pounds a year now obviously we
haven't signed that contract we are
shopping around and looking but it's
such a volatile Market at the minute
that nobody knows where those prices are
sitting and where they're going to be
and if that business price cap does come
in and say it's even only half that but
that still is a an increase of you know
300 many many businesses are going to
struggle with paying that I mean listen
I recognize that myself on a personal
basis I'm in a very different position
but as an industry it's going to
struggle it's going to be very very
difficult to deal with if you think of
those amazing lovely local pubs that you
know the the gorgeous little uh uh um
City Center bars and restaurants and
spaces where the landlord perhaps lives
upstairs and and maybe able is able to
EK to salary uh of you know 25 30 000
pounds a year but um because they live
upstairs but if their energy increases
to another 25 30 40 50 100 000 pound a
year then these businesses just become
absolutely non-viable and and it's it's
a real shame because that's the reality
for many places in Hospitality that
those margarines sit on those few
percentage points
yeah and it's I'm guessing it's not just
uh pubs and restaurants like yours it's
the suppliers and it's all the other
companies that you're working with as
well
yeah that's exactly that you look at
Food inflation in the way that that's
hitting the industry and then uh you
know those business costs those Energy
prices are going into butchers they're
going into Farmers they're going into
fish members and all those sorts of
suppliers and then what happens from
there is that that is obviously a
parallel cost that comes into the
business
um and what happens then is it's
inevitable that those costs are going to
have to go up and the prices then go up
on the menu but at the same point
everybody at home is sitting there with
a uh with less money in their pocket so
what happens is that you know
hospitality is one point but it's the
same for everybody it's the same for
retail and Manufacturing that the end
cost of an ingredient sits at one point
and the money in people's pocket is
another and it feels like it's pulling
two polars apart
so what does the government need to do
to help businesses like yours going
forward
so I mean obviously the business price
cap coming in is something that's um
obviously going to be of a great help to
many many businesses we just need to
know a little bit more of the detail in
that um but there's no there's a number
of things that the government could do I
think um a review and a look at the
business rates and the way that they're
calculated Hospitality gets punished
quite heavily on business rates you know
it's it's calculated on the rateable
value of the business and that business
appears to be a heavier in a Hospitality
space and it does perhaps the majority
of the High Street but also Frontline
tax breaks in terms of vat a decrease
would be incredibly helpful for many
businesses up front and reducing the
amount that you pay incorporating tax is
fantastic that is great but that only
works if there's a business that's
making profit so any help that the
government needs to do for for
Hospitality for manufacturing should
come in as a Frontline reduction in vat
that will allow your business to operate
and particularly whether that's for
short-term whether it's a six month 12
month or 18 month opportunity to get
through these difficult
um winter period
um while we've got you I wondered if you
had any sort of tips that you could
share with people at home for keeping
bills and and costs down um as a chef
I'm thinking obviously we spend a lot of
money on our energy bills in the kitchen
don't we yeah absolutely you know we we
do it you spend a lot of time cooking I
mean one of the big things one of the
big things I would say is menu planning
or organize what you're going to do
um and how you're going to cook it
during the week like it it doesn't it's
not necessarily the most creative every
evening that you go and go what am I
going to cook this evening but if you've
got that structure you keep your costs
down on your food costs you know you buy
just exactly what you need and have a
look at batch cooking so if you're going
to cook a a large portion of bolognese
sauce for example you know do it for two
weeks worth and and freeze it so the
next time all you've got to do is reheat
it rather than cook it for the next hour
and a half but little tricks and tips
like that they all go a long long way
cooking things in one pan
um and just the opportunity of trying to
do things that are a little bit quicker
as well
okay just before I let you go what's
your message to quasi quattang where
there's mini budget tomorrow
yeah I mean I hope that you've been
listening to many members of the
industry that have been um sending uh
emails and and letters and direct
conversation
um regarding a reduction in vat and uh
very much a review of business rates so
uh you know we're very hopeful but it's
it's a critical couple of days
um for for the hospitality industry and
many others around